[Musique]
un bonsoir et bienvenue très heureux de
vous retrouver pour le journal de la
rédaction et bonne année 2022 nous
sommes le mardi 4 janvier voici les
titres
c'est le plus grand rendez vous de
l'innovation le cs computer electronics
show débute demain à las vegas comme
chaque année les yvelines seront
représentées sur place notamment par
l'aide comme installé à
vélizy-villacoublay qui développe le
l'ifi la connexion internet grâce à la
lumière led elle a ouvert voici trois
ans à chanteloup les vignes les potirons
est une épicerie solidaire proposant des
produits locaux en circuit court ses
salariés des personnes en difficulté
professionnelle et sociale rencontre et
puis une découverte le citer parmi les
derniers du genre en ile-de-france la
champignonnière des carrières est
installé avec mon depuis 2016 le site
est spécialisé dans une production
régionale traditionnels on vous y emmène
à la fin de cette édition
la déferlante du variant omicron qui
continuent de toucher les yvelines
d'après les derniers chiffres le taux
d'incidence a franchi la barre des 2000
cas pour 100000 habitants dans le
département ce une augmentation de 100
2,98 % en une semaine une vingtaine de
nouvelles hospitalisations duo kobe de
19 sont recensés chaque jour sur le
territoire dont cinq en soins critiques
un million cent 2139 personnes ont reçu
à ce jour au moins deux doses de vaccins
dans les yvelines
l'hôpital privé du monde garder le
centre cardiologique des vêtements vont
fusionner une décision prise par le
groupe vivalto santé le nouveau site
sera implantée à aubergenville à
proximité immédiate de l'autoroute a13
et du futur rer eole mathilde franco
mélanie poké et mickaël el nido en 15
ans le nombre d'habitants de plus de 60
ans sein de la communauté urbaine grand
paris seine et oise a augmenté de 30%
face à ce constat le groupe vivalto
santé a choisi de regrouper l'hôpital
dumont garder le centre cardiologique
des vêtements à aubergenville le nouveau
site sortir à l'horizon 2024 sur un
terrain de 20 mille mètres carrés
appartenant à la communauté urbaine est
assis particulier la clinique sera ici à
cet emplacement là et puis nous avons
bien entendu nécessité d'offrir
aux patients et aux professionnels de
santé un véritable parking un lieu
d'accueil pour les véhicules nous avons
et sommes nous aurons la station de bus
et je crois le deuxième arrêt au départ
de la gare donc toutes les commodités
seront là mais cette annonce est un coup
dur pour la commune des vêtements pour
moi c'était une surprise je l'appris
donc par le maire d'aubergenville
qui m'a prévenu sous conseils de sophie
primas la sénatrice nous demandons
basque avec moi ils sont bien le courant
que la clinique va fusionner avec celle
de berre c'est dommage pour rêver qu'on
passe que nous ils sont là depuis
259 et à près de deux cents lits donc
c'est quand même une clinique qui tourne
en a de mémoire je retourne 5000
patients qui passent par an donc oui ça
fait quand même du trafic ça fait du
volume dans le village - le groupe
vivalto santé le troisième acteur
hospitalier privé français excède king
dans le département des yvelines sa
volonté renforcer significativement
l'offre de soins dans le nord des épines
il y aura aussi de vraies dimensions des
d'amélioration des circuits déficience
même de la prise en charge limiter les
transferts inter établissements
mutualisé aussi tous nos plateaux
techniques on est vraiment aussi sur
cette dimension de recherche de
l'efficience de nos organisations mais
c'est aussi pour nous l'occasion de
permettre aussi une activité en tout cas
un lieu d'exercice qui sera amélioré et
modernisé pour nos équipes avec un total
de 258 la future clinique concentrera
des prises en charge lourdes comme la
cardiologie la pneumologie ainsi que des
soins critiques elle permettra également
de nourrir la coordination entre les
différentes disciplines médicales
[Musique]
le cs 2022 ouvre ses portes demain
mercredi à las vegas l'événement annuel
rassemble les acteurs de l'innovation
technologique pour cette édition 140
start up françaises seront sur place
pour porter haut et fier l'étendard de
la french tech c'est l'occasion pour
nous de voir ce qui se cache est
derrière ce terme de la french tech
aussi les mots utilisés par les acteurs
de ce milieu avec nous nicolas landry
bonsoir bonsoir de la rédaction de tv
soit 118 alors commençons par
l'essentiel le mot french tech ça veut
dire quoi french touch le mode french
tech en fait c'est un label qui a été
lancée en 2013 par le gouvernement
français il vient labellisé un
territoire d'innovation où sont
présentes des start-up souvent sous la
forme d'une association prenons un
exemple un depuis 2010 9 la french tech
paris saclay couvre un territoire à
cheval entre l'essonne et les yvelines
elle rassemble aujourd'hui 500 startups
entre palaiseau et versailles en passant
par saint quentin en yvelines parmi
elles trois cent cinquante sont engagés
dans la deep tech alors il ya ce
deuxième terme de la deep tech sas écrit
des deux ep ça veut dire quoi deep tech
alors la deep tech en bon français c'est
la technologie de rupture c'est un
produit ou un service innovant qui va
remplacer une technologie en place sur
un marché un exemple parlant grégory 1
c'est le streaming vidéo par rapport au
dvd et vous avez plusieurs domaines
d'activités de rupture présente à paris
saclay l'informatique quantique la
cybersécurité l'afutt tech la medtech ou
encore la robotique ces startups ont une
importante valorisation valorisation
mais il n'y a pas encore de licorne sur
le territoire de paris saclay licorne
c'est justement un terme qui peut
surprendre ça veut dire quoi licorne
aussi alors ne pensez pas à l'animal
légendaire avec une corne sur le front
les licornes en économie désigne des
start up dont leur valeur dépasse le
milliard d'euros ce sont des entreprises
avec une croissance exponentielle qui
peuvent se permettre de lever des fonds
de manière importante c'est à dire
qu'elles se financent très facilement
auprès des investisseurs et vous
connaissez sûrement un délit quand
française grégory baugé a été aidé par
l'animation il ya d'octo libre dont on
parle beaucoup en ce moment je crois
qu'il ya 10 heures aussi dans le domaine
de la musique deezer vous avez aussi
blabla cas ou encore le serveur
informatique ovh voilà des licornes
française qui aujourd'hui valent plus
d'un milliard d'euros merci nicolas pour
ces précisions et justement on va
recevoir dans ce journal un représentant
fier représentant 2 french tech c'est
benjamin azoulay qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bon soir
bonjour alors pour vous c'est ce que
vous êtes en direct depuis las vegas il
est 9h du matin à las vegas vous
participez aux crs de las vegas avec
votre société vous êtes le co2 l'aide
comme l'entreprise est installée à
vélizy villacoublay à développer le lit
fille ça veut dire light fidelity c'est
un système de communication sans fil qui
utilise est la lumière led et la
technologie a été développée notamment
les recherches ont été menées à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines en essayant d'être le plus
pédagogique possible comment ça
fonctionne concrètement le lit fier
alors le lit fils et c'est l'acronyme de
light fidelity c'est un peu comme le
wifi mais au lieu d'utiliser des ondes
radiofréquences pour se connecter à
internet nous allons utiliser des led
nous allons éteindre et rallumer les led
à très grande vitesse 30 millions de
fois par seconde qui est totalement
invisible à l'oeil nu et grâce à cela
nous arrivons nous connecter à internet
alors quels sont les gros avantage c'est
d'abord une sécurité absolue quasiment
c'est à dire que le signal ne va pas
être accable à l'extérieur de la pièce
c'est également une connexion sans ondes
radiofréquences dans certains endroits
de l'hôpital dans une école dans dans
certains sites industriels ou les ondes
radiofréquences ne sont pas tolérés ou
ne sont pas autorisés on a une connexion
sans fil possible et enfin c'est une vie
c'est une connexion qui est ultra rapide
avec une très faible latence le temps de
réponse de 0,5 me seconde donc très
intéressant vous parliez de la connexion
internet c'est forcément le premier
usage auquel on pense il ya d'autres
possibilités 1 grâce aussi à cette
technologie
oui bien sûr il faut voir le lit fille
comme étant une solution de remplacement
de câbles partout les ondes
radiofréquences ne sont pas autorisés je
vais vous donner des exemples un des
premiers marchés que l'entreprise va
aborder sa lettre le spatial et
l'aéronautique parce que remplaçant du
cap dans des satellites dans des
lancements des avions on allège
énormément les engins spatiaux par
exemple on va faire interner gagné 5 kg
sur un petit satellite constellation
donc très intéressant on va pouvoir
également dans certains environnements
comme la défense
pouvoir fournir une connectivité sans
fil donc éviter du câble parfois
extrêmement lourd et difficile à main en
oeuvre dans les environnements où la
sécurité informatique est absolue donc
qu'on peut pas utiliser de russie voit
la façon d exemple et bien sûr petit à
petit le weed le lift y arrive j'allais
dire proche du grand public on a
commencé par les écoles notamment avec
avec cette fameuse tablette que nous
présentons à las vegas est une tablette
android c'est la première tablette
nativement équipé en wifi vous voyez le
on a au dessus d'un émetteur récepteur
qui nous permet de quidams aux élèves de
se connecter à internet dans une salle
de classe sans ondes radiofréquences et
avec une très très bonne connexion
extrêmement donc c'est la technologie
vous allez présenter sur ce s justement
vous avez rencontré en 2017 vous étiez à
l'aube de cette phase
d'industrialisation d'arriver sur le
marché grand public est ce que vous
l'avez pris ce tournant ça se fait petit
à petit c'est ce que ce que vous dites
voilà le lit fille est en train de se
développer d'abord sur des marchés be to
be comme souvent d'ailleurs ce type de
technologie et va petit à petit arrivée
dans le grand public je parlais du
spatial je parlais de la défense je peux
parler aussi de l'automobile on a des
applications de communication de
véhicule infrastructure petit à petit ce
sont les premiers segments qui vont
adopter la technologie et au fur et à
mesure de la miniaturisation on est en
train de de lancer une circuit intégré
ce qu'on appelle c'est à dire que la
technologie devient tout petit et on
commence à avoir des premières tablettes
et demain des smartphones qui vont être
équipés avec cette technologie est donc
permettre l'accès à la technologie à
tout le monde dans des écoles mais aussi
à la maison
pour faire du home office par exemple
nicolas landry
plusieurs secteurs d'activité avec
lesquels vous travaillez vous parlez de
la spatiale de l'aéronautique de
l'automobile
vous avez parlé aussi de l'école
numérique qui est présente sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
tous ces secteurs sont aussi présents
sur les i bis concrètement comment ça se
passe avec les acteurs illinois dans ces
secteurs d'activité comment vous
travaillez avec qui peut-être vous
travaillez
écoutez on a on a commencé on était
présent à l'est du québec
ça nous a permis d'avoir une très belle
exposition et de rencontre énormément de
collectivités territoriales alors je
peux citer par exemple la première
commune dans les épines qui sera équipé
de technologies c'est ce sont les clefs
sous voile à l'école maternelle doivent
pas renoncer la crèche c'est une des
crèches des clayes-sous-bois qui va être
puisque vous savez qu'en france on n'a
pas le droit d'exposer des enfants de
moins de 3 ans aux ondes radiofréquences
et on a besoin parfois de connectivité
pour par exemple les parents plus
reconnaître avoir avoir des informations
en ligne et donc on a on commence à
s'alléger rendez vous avec avec des
personnes à la mairie tbilissi pour
commencer à envisager le déploiement
dans les écoles on commence par les
écoles maternelles ou les crèches
puisque c'est l'urgence prédit dans ces
environnements là les ondes
radiofréquences sont prohibées et petit
à petit on commence à avoir des collèges
intéressé d'épicés également
dernière question benjamin souley le
programme sur place pour ce crs 2022
quel est il
écoutez on a on a démarré hier par un
événement qui s'appelle le csm bio c'est
un événement médiatique pressé e s on a
rencontré énormément de journaliste on a
on entend parler de nous maintenant un
peu partout on a des articles en russie
en chine au vietnam donc c'est une très
belle exposition médiatique pour
l'entreprise et à partir de demain matin
alors de las vegas le célèbre acteur le
lui-même commence pendant pendant trois
jours le ciel s cette année a été
raccourcie d'une journée on a un peu
moins de un peu moins de 2
exposants et un peu moins de visiteurs
lyoko vide mais on est quand même très
très heureux d'avoir pu participer à ce
serait ce parce que pour une entreprise
comment dire start up c'est
l'opportunité de faire des très belles
rencontres notamment dans le bitume et
vous y serez donc jusqu'au 8 janvier
c'est la date de clôture de crs 2022 à
las vegas merci d'avoir été avec nous
benjamin soler merci locaux colette
commerciaux arrêtent avec nous mêmes par
distances avec le décalage horaire 1
puisqu'il est actuellement 9 heures un
peu plus de neuf heures maintenant à las
vegas
[Musique]
elle a été créée il ya trois ans par
l'association et qualys les potirons est
une épicerie solidaire qui emploient du
personnel en insertion professionnelle
est la boutique propose des produits
locaux obtenu en circuit court grâce à
des jardins de cocagne la rencontre est
signé céline charles dans ses jardins
familiaux il est 10 heures en plein
hiver et ces travailleurs n'ont pas
froid aux yeux plantation de fleurs de
légumes de fraises ici travail de la
terre se conjugue à la rigueur qu'exige
le milieu professionnel pour venir en
aide à des profits tous différents au
quotidien on fait des plantations en
fait c'est pour montrer aux gens qu'on
peut planter sur des petites parcelles
une véritable passerelle restructurantes
pour ces adultes en perte de repères en
recherche d'emploi ils ont été tes
départ et qualys une association qui a
parmi ses objectifs
l'insertion par l'activité économique
c'est pas forcément pour en faire des
futurs jardiniers ou des techniciens en
espaces verts pour les collectivités
mais c'est surtout un support qui leur
permet de se redynamiser de sortir d'un
peu de leur quotidien et d'être
accompagnés vers un véritable projet
professionnel l'idée c'est vraiment de
leur redonner d un cadre au niveau du
professionnel savoir arriver à l'heure
le savoir être
présent ne pas être absents écouter des
consignes comme dans n'importe quelle
entreprise professionnellement ça
m'apporte beaucoup non seulement le
savoir être et le savoir faire que
j'avais déjà mais ça c'est un plus une
belle occasion également pour les
rencontres et le partage c'est vraiment
un échange chacun
à son sens son sens son savoir donc tous
les savoirs son partage on a vraiment
cet esprit d'équipé en parallèle aux
jardins familiaux une boutique a ouvert
il ya trois ans à chanteloup les vignes
elle emploie également du personnel en
insertion la création de cette boutique
il ya plusieurs objectifs c'était de
répondre à un besoin de commerces de
proximité offrir voilà aux habitants des
produits locaux et des fruits et légumes
bio 2 c'était de créer de l'emploi et
permettre à des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi donc sans emploi de retrouver
du travail et de venir travailler dans
ce dispositif qu'est la boutique et 3
c'était de le troisième objectif c'était
de travailler avec les agriculteurs
locaux et de valoriser la production
locale avec un même objectif servir de
tremplin les personnes qui travaillent
dans cette boutique sont des salariés en
insertion ou en transition
professionnelle on dit parce que ce sont
des personnes qui sont à la base à la
recherche d'un emploi donc sans emploi
on est un tremplin pour eux pour les
aider à retrouver un emploi plus perrin
derrière j'étais un chercheur d'emploi
et un concert j'ai récemment parlé de
cette association du coup
voilà j'ai fait en sorte de postuler ici
ça me permettait d'intégrer d'où son nom
de travail une initiative valorisante
pour le personnel depuis le début je
veux dire sam emporté de la confiance ça
c'est important ça permet de renouer
avec le monde du travail au centre la
première chose qu'on va regarder c'est
sur mon cv cécile et j'ai de
l'expérience dans ce domaine et là
c'est le car j'apprends un cercle
vertueux entre productions locales et
vente de proximité qui permet à de
nombreuses personnes de retrouver le
chemin de l'emploi chaque année le sport
du football et un yvelinois sur le
devant de la scène edward michu 18 ans a
connu hier lundi la première
titularisation de sa carrière avec le
paris saint germain le coach mauricio
pochettino l'a aligné au milieu de
terrain aux côtés de marco v ratier
d'ander herrera pour affronter vannes en
16e de finale de la coupe de france les
joueurs formés ou chesnay versailles a
même failli marquer regarder sentir
s'est écrasé sur la barre du portier de
vannes clément pétrels le psg l'a
emporté facilement 4-0 avec des buts de
cris pembe et un triplé de bap et vous
voyez le quatrième but de kylie ann bape
et quatrième buts pour le paris saint
germain et son troisième but hier pour
l'attaquant français le psg a des douars
michu qui pourrait être le prochain
adversaire du fc versailles en coupe de
france le tirage au sort des huitièmes
de finale a lieu ce mardi soir à 20
heures ça pourrait être du lourd pour
les yvelinois parmi les 16 dernières
équipes neuf écuries de ligue 1 donc
avec le psg l'olympique de marseille
monaco nice ou encore une équipe entre
lens et lille qui s'affrontent ce soir
quatre clubs de ligue 2 également dont
toulouse et bastia enfin aux côtés dé
versailles et un autre représentant de
la nationale 2 c'est la quatrième
division nationale c'est bergerac quoi
qu'il advienne le parcours de versailles
est déjà exceptionnel le ces versets qui
jouera pour la première fois de son
histoire au stade des huitièmes de
finale de cette compétition
avant de vous laisser cette découverte
en ile de france il ne reste que très
peu de champignonnières l'une d'elles se
trouve avec mon le site est spécialisé
dans une production régionale
traditionnel mathilde francou essenine
charles nous font visiter ce lieu angèle
moioli fait partie des cinq derniers
champignonnistes d'ile-de-france il
institua et vêtements une commune dans
le nord des yvelines depuis 2016 il fait
pousser des champignons de paris dans
les carrières de pierre mais pas que
allons découvrir tout ça
[Musique]
alors vous êtes champignons ni d'où
vient cette passion des champignons une
passe on va qui vient de naissance
puisque ma famille toute la famille
chopin liszt mon grand père était
cheminot nice mais pas en maison toute
la famille était dans le champion j'ai
été bercé dans ce métier là et ça m'a
toujours plu purée c'est dans ce métier
là est la particularité d'ici c'est que
bah vous récoltez vous élever vos
champignons dans une carrière qu'est ce
que ça donne aux champignons comme vous
qu'est ce que c'est alors une carrière
déjà on voit déjà le lieu est un
c'est un blizzard
le lieu il ya l'odeur ce champignon
c'est un filtre
il respire il ya des odeurs sur quoi ça
pousse c'est où ça pousse donc déjà donc
il va prendre son temps de l'absorber
c'est l'humidité ambiante
l'odeur du fumier de la terre de
gobetage d'apprendre ce goût ou en train
et les températures très basses nous à
dire 13 14 15 16 devrait donc ça évolue
tranquillement
ils attendent absorbé dans une
consistance
donc il ya ce parfum il est roi comme
l'industriel où il l'un d'eux serait
l'époux sera très vite pour ce très
chaud beaucoup d'eau c'est comme la
tomate de ces automates de terrain c'est
la même chose sauf que monaco le soleil
mais on a le lieu le goût l'odeur qui se
fait
donc et tout prix légumes qui prend son
temps une consistance et un bout c'est
surtout ça et nous on n'a rien on se
base sur sa sur le goût le goût et les
traditions de travail ouais et alors où
est ce que vous les fait plus effet
champignons je laissais pousse un petit
peu plus loin devant la cave on va
découvrir tout ça bah oui je vous fais
remonter tout ça elle était partie de la
partie on y va
[Musique]
on n'a pas le
temps de se dire voilà il est rond et
que les comptes bonjour a pu laisser
grossir encore un peu plus et va grossir
il n'ya plus plat et ici ça va se voir
peut-être vouloir s'ouvrir comme on va
le cas c'est super il ya plus plat
mais encore à membrane ne commence à
aller encore collé mais commence à
s'affiner
si j'attends grimpent eux il n'ya plus
en plus paris la basse éclatée donc le
stade la foule a fallu cueillir même un
petit peu avant bon là ils sont en
paquet donc ceux qui sont ou vont
arriver plus vite en maturité et avec
des jambes plus longues puisqu'ils
veulent passer par dessus les autres qui
quand ils sont à pin up ce stade là on
arrive à les voir faire grossir mais
tous les jours faut que je gêne là
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure je vais
accueillir tout cela tout cela ils sont
mûrs tout cela ça pour pro demain après
là il ya quelques instants là au départ
bah faut faire des sacrifices on va dire
où on laisse plus mûr pour demain où je
passe je sélectionne je dois faire 500
kg par semaine à peu près d'accord et
vous les vendez ensuite c'est
aujourd'hui oui je produis qu'est-ce que
j'en vois là et dans mes clients je ne
bois 100 kg en moyenne par semaine j'ai
besoin mais vous les vendre à des
particuliers
je travaille avec des particuliers ici
sur le point de vente fin de semaine des
commerçants qui sont les marchés des
maraîchers qu'on les points de vente sur
l'exploitation beaucoup les épiceries
des restaurateurs une cantine les gars
qui font les paniers de fruits et
légumes aussi pour les entreprises et
puis je travaille beaucoup avec des
associations des amap possible
alors ici c'est complètement différent
des champignons de paris c'est pas la
même façon de travailler ici c'est que
dans les sacs vous êtes la paille qui
est pasteurisé
broyé pasteurisé ans pensait
puisque cissé de la pleurote les niveaux
requis ligne de la limite le bois il
faut que la structure a soit plus dur
que le champion de paris c'est le
compost parce que ça sera composté parce
que là faut que ça soit nous vous plus
déconner
par contre assez dans des sacs en
plastique noirs c'est pareil de
filaments s'est développée l'intérieur
il ya des trous par contre ici à 8
heures de lumière par jour il ya mille
litres est comme si on serait dehors
faut recréer le sic expérience est eh
bien merci beaucoup un gel pur pour
toute cette découverte puis pour votre
accueil merci aussi à vous des doutes
jusque là
et voilà maintenant vous en savez un peu
plus sur les champignons et moi j'ai
plus qu'à déguster tout ça et je pense
que je vais avoir des champignons
pendant plusieurs mois voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant premier numéro
de l'année pour le 7-8 culture présentée
par célia gars tsongo très belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]